pour l'église catholique la loi
naturelle elle s'impose à toute personne
quel que que cette personne soit
catholique ou pas et la loi naturelle
c'est l'église catholique qui la définit
donc dans l'eau au coeur même de
l'église catholique
il ya cette revendication d'être porteur
d'une loi universelle qui concernait
tous les êtres humains et qui est un 10
ans us avec les principes laïques
dissensus théorie qui n'a pas été résolu
et qui justement le pari d'aristide
briand c'est de dire qui faisait dire en
1905 à beaucoup de gens que le
catholicisme et la république étaient
incompatibles et aristide briand à 10 et
son de poser le problème dans ces termes
se sont posé de problème dans cette âme
voyons de manière pragmatique pratique
comment on peut fonctionner et je crois
que c'est une erreur grave très grave de
recommencer marcel gaucher aurait existé
à 19 ans à qui l'a été contre pie ix ans
il aurait pensé qu'il y avait une
incompatibilité un choc culturel entre
le catholicisme et la république bon non
les problèmes se d'assen loi de dieu
non moi je n'aime pas ce vocabulaire
religieux employés par des républicains
bon ce qu'on la république a constaté c
est ce que les gens dans leur vie
concrète respectent les lois de la
république ou pas et il ya des gens qui
respectent pas les lois de la république
mais me to a montré que ces gens par
exemple sur l'égalité hommes femmes
on est mal placé pour focaliser sa sur
les musulmans étant donné que dans tous
les milieux que l'égalité homme femme
n'a pas été respectée la dignité des
femmes n'a pas été respecté et dans les
milieux les plus branchés les plus in
qui se voulait les plus modernes donc
ayons le même regard pour tout le monde
et demandons à tout le monde de
respecter autant que faire se peut les
principes républicains
mais on n'a pas se soucier de théologie
la théologie c'est une affaire privée
c'est bon c'est pas du tout à la
république de de se focaliser sur telle
ou telle technologie
[Musique]